okay I think we're live my life I think
I am live welcome first stream of 2019 I
have made it clear that one of my goals
for 2019 was to recommit to doing
streams there's been a lot of pent up
demand for them and people saying I wish
you would stream more I wish you would
do more live stuff more playing against
viewers in chess which is funny when you
get crushed because you're terrible
which I will sometimes indulge people in
and all sorts of other stuff so anyway
it today's the first day back in the
studio we did a new show today we did a
new bonus show today and I'm doing a
live stream and I'm going to talk about
Elizabeth Warren I'm going to talk about
the shutdown I may open up the phone
lines I may play chess against people in
the audience I don't know we'll see what
ends up sort of happening in the
meantime let's see if I have all my
stuff working here it is yes okay if
this is your first David Pakman show
live stream this is actually live so a
lot of stuff goes on which is cool
because it's live the best way to send
questions and comments is to use the
super chat function and I will put those
up on screen potentially or at minimum I
will talk about them I will I will
answer your questions and read your
comments new members and patrons get
live thank-yous during the live stream
so if you sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership or patreon.com slash
david pakman show you will get your name
said period I mean that that's just as
simple as it is
and please don't troll the chat okay
please don't troll the chat if it's
subtle and no one notices okay but there
are moderators and if you are obviously
trolling or hating or pasting incredibly
elaborate swastikas made out of
punctuation symbols as some people have
figured out how to do you will be banned
and the monitors are deputized now you
will notice number 5 become a youtube
sponsor get a shout out you'll notice if
you look at the chat as I'm doing right
now that when some people post they have
very
cool logos next to their names that is
because they are YouTube members okay
YouTube membership is beta and I by that
I don't mean it's the alternative to
alpha like an alpha male or a beta male
that's not what I mean what I mean is
that it's a beta feature not every
YouTube channel has it and we are we are
so beta that we are part of a sub beta
test where we actually have five
different tiers of YouTube membership
you hit the join button you can be a soy
boy for a dollar ninety-nine a month in
any way it goes all the way up to 9999 a
month I will also thank those people so
like if you're looking to get involved
in this live stream there are many many
ways to do that okay I also have now the
ability so but before we get started I
will say we should come up with some way
to determine whether I either number one
open up the phone lines for the show
right now the phone lines are closed
sometimes during live streams I will
open up the phone lines and people can
call in also if people want I will play
a game or two of chess I'm David Pakman
on Lee chess org that's a lie chess org
last night I was just casually playing
and I was matched up randomly with
someone who said I'm watching the David
Pakman show on YouTube right now so I'm
David Pakman on Lee chess org if you
want to send challenges you can do it
but I'm not necessarily going to play
chess on today's stream maybe what we
will do is is the following if maybe
we'll do it with patreon contributions
if you want me to open the phone lines
make a patreon pledge ending in one
penny so like a dollar and one cent two
dollars and one cent whatever that's a
vote for phone calls if you want me to
do live chess against viewers do a
donation that is in Oh - so pledge a
dollar in two cents a month or two
dollars in two cents a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
if you just want me to do both do an O
three okay so like a dollar and three
cents would be a vote for both opening
up the phone lines and playing some
chess will give it till the bottom of
the hour so it'll be like a half hour of
voting patreon pledge ending and oh one
means phone lines
only patreon pledge ending in O 2 means
chess only and patreon pledge ending in
O 3 means open the phone lines for a
little bit and then pay play a couple
games of chess and I will communicate to
you which is winning as we go here ok so
let's get right into some of the news
which I should be able to put up yes
here we go
ok you can now see the articles I'm
looking at there is every indication
that this live this government shut down
rather is going to go on for a while and
Donald Trump has been sort of
positioning himself as being the guy
who's open to negotiation and the guy
who as soon as Democrats are ready to be
reasonable as he likes to say meaning
give him money to pay for a wall that
Mexico was supposedly going to be paying
for by now then he will get the deal
done to open the government back up and
it it is not going to well new
Washington Post article Trump falsely
claims Mexico is paying for the wall and
demands taxpayer money for the wall in a
meeting with Democrats so he I guess
today in another sign that he let's if
we can close these distracting odds in
another sign that he wants to appear
reasonable but is actually saying things
that make no sense whatsoever
Trump had another meeting with Democrats
Democrats had a plan to reopen key parts
of the federal government as the
Washington Post says he's demanding five
billion to build new walls and walls is
an important operative word there
because these are sections of wall like
the five billion would would only cover
a small fraction of that border we know
that the total border could cost a total
total border wall could be twenty
billion could be thirty billion who even
knows at this point doesn't even matter
it's a political football he wants five
billion to build new walls on the border
Democrats said no we're not going to do
that House Democrats are planning to put
forward legislation that would reopen
some parts of government but would not
provide money to Trump for the wall
and Trump said he wouldn't sign off on
that measure and meanwhile Trump is
still talking about how Mexico is at
some point going to pay for the wall how
it's going to happen at this point we
don't really know and I'll be you know
my biggest problem with these shutdowns
there's basically two problems with them
one is if you are so-called small
government conservative who wants
government doing as little as possible
you don't care if government is shut
down in other words you don't want
government doing stuff so you might say
it's a great thing that the government
is shut down even if you say Trump is
responsible which he is you don't
necessarily see it as a bad thing that's
one problem that these shutdowns
inherently have which is there is one
political movement in this country that
wants the government doing as little as
possible so they don't even see when we
say who is to blame for the shutdown
who's responsible is almost a better way
to say it and they like that the
government is shut down
so systemically even if the shutdown is
the fault of the result of a Republican
president or Republicans in the House or
Senate there are people who want it shut
down for as long as possible number two
it's not even really a shutdown right
that's another part of the problem which
is that by some estimates only between
ten and fifteen percent of government
functions and departments are actually
shut down when there is a so-called
government shutdown elected officials
still get paid so much stuff is actually
happening so if instead when there was a
government shutdown people stopped
receiving Social Security checks
Medicare stopped accepting claims
elected officials didn't get paid
Elizabeth Warren by the way is donating
her Senate salary during the time that
the government is shut down you would
actually see outrage and it would be
much more difficult from people on the
right who wants small government to say
I don't care leave it shut down as long
as they want because I don't want
government doing stuff so that's a
systemic problem with this shutdown and
it's one that unfortunately
we favors the right it favors the right
it favors the government remaining shut
down and that is going to be a major
problem for Democrats particularly as
they are sworn in and taking control
because whether or not blame shifts to
them and this has been a question once
Democrats take control of the house even
though it's ridiculous will they start
to be blamed for this shutdown even
though they had nothing to do of course
with starting it and even if they're not
there is a contingent of the American
political world that wants the
government to to remain shutdown so this
is a problem for Democrats even though
it's not actually their problem and it
III don't know ultimately what's going
to happen in terms of the timing of it
but Donald Trump is already playing coy
to some degree of success okay I'm gonna
get before we get to Elizabeth Warren
let me talk about some of the super
chats that are coming in you can send a
super chat using the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window on the table
for this live stream I may open the
phones and take phone calls if people
want
I may play against people on Leech s org
if people want to challenge me in chess
I'm not very good but people seem to
find it fun and funny when I play
against people in chess from the
audience and sometimes get crushed or do
you want me to do both we are voting via
patreon pledge okay patreon.com slash
david pakman show if you want me to open
the phone lines make a pledge ending in
a penny so a dollar and one cent two
dollars and one cent etc if you want me
only to play chess with people in the
audience make a contribution ending in
Oh - a dollar Oh - two dollars Oh - and
if you want me to do both make a patreon
pledge ending in oh three a dollar oh
three 2.03 whatever and then I will do
that but before we get to that let's get
this some super chats
platypi sends a - Australian dollar
super chat saying just happy new year
everyone much love thank you appreciate
that
kirk wilcox sends a $2 super chat what
are your thoughts on Space Jam
loved the movie Space Jam but even
better than Space Jam in terms of I
think nineties basketball themed movies
blue chips blue chips with Nick Nolte
and Shaquille O'Neal paint playing
Louisiana basketball player neon bodeaux
and Penny Hardaway and some white guy
who I don't even know if he was actually
a basketball player but he played a
basketball player from Indiana that is
one of my favorite a fictional
basketball movies if you haven't seen it
check it out
Kirk thank you for the super chat gr in
the house with the $2 super chat saying
pack D Z the G with free speech be love
gr Thank You gr great to welcome 2019
with the incoherent rantings of gr Dave
with a $2.00 super chat saying Kony 2020
yeah warrants no response whatsoever but
I appreciate the support
normal viewer for a dollar ninety-nine
says finally real news thank you no
thank you normal viewer for your support
JH WH kadhal says that with a two euro
super chat happy new year loving your
show from Vienna Austria thank you I'm
actually looking at getting out to
Vienna sometime in life I wish I could
be more precise than that but I can't
right now
Martin Alejandra's for a dollar no
question or comment thank you Bess pay
with a $2.00 super chat thoughts on the
secret Pentagon UFO program if it's
secret I wouldn't know anything about it
so I don't have any thoughts and CJ $5
what do you think is the best way to
convert a trump supporter assuming you
mean how to convert them to
progressivism or to stop being trumpets
I really don't know one piece of advice
that I've given people who have called
in saying I've got trumpets in my family
or last last week we had a call on the
Friday show an Australian viewer who has
a trumpet
his girlfriend's parents are trumpets I
said you know you need to consider what
your goals are if your goal is to take
them for a full from a full full
trumpets to someone who's gonna vote for
Bernie I don't really know how you do
that I think first you want to start
disabusing them of maybe some of the
false notions that they've integrated
into their belief system about Trump and
the best way I believe to do that is to
just ask questions ask basic questions
about what do you think are the reasons
that Donald Trump was not able to
accomplish X for example or another one
that I've over the weekend a friend
suggested to me is you ask people who
violently disagree with the position of
their political opponents you say okay I
want to talk to you about this so that
we're on the same page what do you
believe is the political position of
your opponents and why do you think that
is their belief so you at least are
getting them to think let's say someone
loves for-profit health care and they
hate single-payer you can say to them
what do you think is the position of
your opponents on this issue what do you
think is the position of those who want
single-payer why do you think they want
it and even if they give you completely
misinformed and cartoonish views about
the motivations of their political
opponents it's going to open the door to
a conversation about hold on a second do
you really think people want
single-payer because they're communists
and they want the government controlling
everything or do you at least think that
they believe that it would get give
people better health care and if you can
get them to concede that if you can get
them to say okay listen I don't agree
with single-payer but I do believe that
the people who want single-payer want it
because they think it's the best way to
get care to the people who need it
getting them just to concede that is
going to reframe it in their minds where
okay I guess I'm not dealing with bad
people on the other side and then you
can maybe say are there places where
that system has worked and of course if
they say no it's an opportunity to
inform them well actually there are
places where
such a single-payer system has worked if
they say yes there are you've now gotten
them to concede that their political
opponents want single-payer for a pretty
good moral reason so that people get the
care that they need and you've gotten
them to concede that it works in some
places now yes they will immediately say
here's ten reasons why it wouldn't work
in the United States and that's okay
you've already made some progress so I
think that that type of questioning that
at least is not overtly judgmental is
one of the best ways to not necessarily
change minds but at least get people to
re-examine re-examine their beliefs
the other big story we talked about on
the regular show today is that Elizabeth
Warren is effectively running for
president in 2020
and the formal announcement is that she
is launching an exploratory committee
but she's been exploring this for some
time we know that we know that the
strategic release of those DNA tests the
DNA test results were related to running
for president so effectively unless
something goes wrong unless she her
exploratory committee finds something
really bad she's running for president
latest news from just a couple of hours
ago is that Elizabeth Warren has hired
Iowa aides as well as top Bernie Sanders
and Obama alums ahead of going to Iowa
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
who announced Monday she's exploring a
presidential run is quickly assembling a
robust and experienced team to lead a
campaign in Iowa an early signal of the
outsized importance of a strong showing
in the state Emily Parcells worked for
Obama in 2008 senior adviser to Hillary
eight years later in 2016
she is now working for Elizabeth Warren
Warren Janus Rotenberg an Ohio organizer
for Clinton working for Elizabeth Warren
former Obama aide tommy viator called
Parcells hiring a huge huge get for
warren saying she's one of the best
political staffers i've ever worked with
and knows everyone in iowa so this is
real and for people who may not
understand what the significance of
starting a
an exploratory committee it lets you do
two things it lets you number one hire
staff that is separate and distinct from
from her Senate staff that just works on
the campaign that's really important and
number two it allows you to start
raising money which becomes part of the
campaign money if you officially launch
a bid for the presidency so again every
indication that Elizabeth Warren is a
serious contender I already went over on
the broadcast show today question number
one what is the political consequence of
Elizabeth Warren entering the race this
early and interestingly we looked at
what are the differences in policy and
ideology between Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders and if indeed Bernie
Sanders decides to run for president we
are going to have a ton of time just a
ton of time to look at the minutiae of
where they differ on policy but to
summarize in 30 seconds what I did in
more time and you can look at it on our
Channel shortly on today's show is that
Elizabeth Warren comes from the world of
law school and business and let's tweak
our capitalist system to be better for
workers
that's her approach which is sort of
capitalism to social democracy is the
way we could kind of couch it Bernie
Sanders instead comes from the world of
more actually socialistic let's totally
reframe and restructure the means of
production over into well more pragmatic
would be social democracies so they end
up on the same policies in a lot of ways
they both support single-payer but on
some issues you can see how their their
world views differ so on education
Elizabeth Warren wants to make it so
that we maintain roughly the same
education system that we have except we
make higher education more accessible to
the most needy people Bernie wants to
pay for public college and university
through government revenues be it
taxation or reallocation of existing
funds
both would be an improvement on what we
have now but they are different
approaches and we're gonna have plenty
of time if indeed Bernie announces that
he's running to get to dig into that in
more detail let's look at a couple of
other super chats NYX propolis sent the
$9 $0.99 super chat are you testing to
see how many live views do you get
during the TYT live show good call I
actually did not know that I was
competing with the TYT live show I don't
know when anybody airs I have no idea
other than I know Sam cedar airs at noon
Eastern I think because when we're out
in Vegas at a conference that we go to a
couple times a year he always does the
show at the same time and it's 9:00 a.m.
Pacific so I think Sam's on at noon but
I had no idea TYT was on now Alexander
Vaughn angle Berg with a - is it CHF is
that CHF Swiss francs I think it is what
is your opinion of Sam Harris I've
talked about Sam Harris before big
picture I think that he's brilliant I
think that he brings very interesting
discussions to the table on a wide
variety of issues he is no doubt and
intellectual every time I talk about the
intellectual dark web containing
pseudo-intellectuals people say but Sam
Harris is he's not a pseudo intellectual
is he no he's not he's an intellectual I
questioned some of the ways that he has
given platforms less than critically to
some bad ideas including the Murray race
and IQ bell curve stuff but there's no
question that Sam Harris is a thinker
and an intellectual and period that that
that's about it doesn't mean I have to
agree with him about everything best pay
$2 super Chad the New York Times
reported on it last year a program
called a ATI P I guess that's referring
to their first Super chat about a secret
Pentagon program on UFOs I will look
into that Lenny Lenny rhymer with a 20
Danish is a Danish Krone or kroner
I never remember I was in Denmark and
what I recall is you divide by four I
think to get two dollars from Danish
currency so I think that's about five
bucks no question or comment thank you I
appreciate it
Martin Alejandra's Happy New Year David
talk about Trump's impeachment well I'll
talk about it if and when it happens I
think that there are a number of paths
forward but I do believe that Donald
Trump presidency survives 2019 I think
that's the most likely scenario and we
addressed that on an audience question
right before the end of 2018 a say
Tanaka with a five dollar super jet I
used to be a right winger Shapiro fanboy
until I stumbled upon yours and Kyle's
his channel and now I consider myself a
progressive thanks to you guys thank you
a say I appreciate that
Antonio Lopez with a two euro 29 cent
super chat hi from Spain Ola with espana
una would also sing again in Spanish hi
from Spain hugs a hug Thank You Antonio
a Smith with a $2.00 super jet who wins
in a fight oh I just scrolled past it
Han this looked good who wins in a fight
jimmy dore or michael brooks after a
stroke um jimmy dore jimmy dore wins in
that scenario biz Wiz $4 $0.99 super
chet the right hates it when artists and
athletes speak about political and
social issues like eminem do you like it
when artists use their platform for this
the right hates it when left-wing
athletes and artists speak about
political and social issues I don't hear
any complaints from the right about all
the country music artists not of course
the Dixie Chicks
but many music country music artists are
conservative and they say conservative
things at their concerts and the right
doesn't give a [ __ ] because they only
care about it when it's the Left that's
doing it so I would correct you in that
way I am 100% fine with artist and
athlete artists and athletes using their
platforms for anything they want and
then the free market of ideas will
determine whether they are punished for
doing that when you hear LeBron
make pull
comments and people say he should just
play basketball well you're so offended
by his political commentary vote with
your dollars and don't go watch him play
anymore and then if enough people do
that he might rethink whether he wants
to be making political comments I have
no problem with it
Kanye West don't agree with his trumpian
lunacy but I have no problem with him
saying whatever he wants about Trump if
he wants to do it at concerts I've been
to Green Day shows where Billy Joe
Armstrong talks about politics the
people in the room don't like that he
does that or they don't agree with his
political views they don't go and buy
tickets anymore if Kanye's shows become
political rants that people don't like
people won't buy tickets anymore so I
have no problem whatsoever
what I do have a problem with is when
people are paid to during a certain time
period be doing a particular job right
so an athlete being interviewed after
the game they can say whatever they want
and then it'll be the network's decision
to keep interviewing them or people's
decision whether to go or not when Al
Michaels right-wing football
narrator tell play-by-play guy says
during the 2004 election after during a
New England Patriots game here in
Massachusetts after the refs change a
call that they flip-flopped and we're in
the right state for that alluding to
John Kerry being Brandt the then
Democratic nominee challenger of George
W Bush for president who had been
successfully labeled a flip-flopper by
the Swift Boat Veterans and others that
is not appropriate because he has been
hired by whoever it was at the time to
do a political commentary now should he
be fired that's up to his employer I
don't like that and I don't like how
Michaels and I don't pay attention to
his commentary or anything that he has
to say as a result so that I don't like
I don't think that's the right venue for
it but ultimately it's not my call to
make if his employer is okay with him
using the venue for that what can I do I
can vote with my eyeballs and put him
somewhere else
Diego Morga with a dollar ninety nine
super chat what's your
opinion on the new Mexican president I
am very interested to see what he does
in the country in terms of reforms there
are some real problems in Mexico right
now even more than before
with safety issues in parts of the
country that previously were not quite
as bad the the Cancun area is
straight-up bad I was actually going to
go in February and I don't like to stay
and these minimum security resorts where
you can't leave I like to be in the city
every time I've been to Cancun before I
go into I get out of the hotel zone and
going to downtown Cancun and I like
doing that and it doesn't really appear
to be safe compared to what it was and
so I'm not going to go I'm gonna go
somewhere else
Sinaloa is a no-go zone according to the
State Department I'm not saying it's a
police no-go zone I want to be careful
the US State Department says simply
don't go do not go to that region region
and many other regions and regions that
have admittedly been worse off for a
while so I hope that his populism
translates to some reforms that are good
for the country because I just love
Mexico I love Mexican culture and the
Mexican people and I want to be able to
go to all parts of Mexico without
without worrying Jackson sends a
five-dollar super Chad what is the
strongest argument against single-payer
or Medicare for all you know I don't
know of any strong arguments i I really
don't I think if the strongest argument
just like there none of them are good I
guess you might have to wait for
elective procedures longer than in the
United States if you want to do them at
the hospitals and providers that are
part of the single-payer network but
it's like is that actually a bad thing I
don't know it's hard for me to think of
a good argument against single-payer
maybe the best argument is a lot of
people would lose their jobs because you
would eliminate a lot of bureaucracy
medical billing and a lot of other stuff
and those people will need jobs in order
to continue making money but I think
it's a solvable problem
peace harmony sends a five-dollar super
chat what do you think of tulsi gabbard
for president if you object for what
reasons i don't know enough about her to
object from what i've seen i saw like 10
minutes of it interview she did with
jimmy dore and she seemed to be going
along with some really crazy [ __ ] but i
need to do more research into her to
really say but i'm not finding her super
appealing like if you give me a choice
between warren Bernie or tulsi gabbard
she would be number three for me for
sure the lone chemist setting the
high-water mark for super chats for
today 1999 I'm a video se si a-- stand a
massive fan of yours in your opinion
what is the best movie depicting war
making a somewhat political essay for my
channel and I'm looking for informed
opinions keep doing what you do I don't
really watch war movies so I couldn't
tell you I really you know I couldn't
tell you if you tell me what are even
some more war movies Pearl Harbor from
the late 90s early 2000s whenever Pearl
Harbor versus Windtalkers vs. I'm dating
myself I don't even know I could not
tell you I barely watch war movies and I
unfortunately am the wrong person to ask
but I appreciate the support okay let me
mention that I got a bunch of challenges
on Leech s org and I'm willing to play a
couple of games of chess against people
in the audience but literally nothing is
happening on patreon and we were gonna
vote by patreon so maybe what we'll do
is let's see because I'm getting a bunch
of challenges and some that I would play
what about the following okay so
yesterday was the first day of the year
and we unfortunately I talked about this
last week in 2018 we actually had a net
loss of members for the David Pakman
show and the reason that that was the
case is we had ad pocalypse in 2017
where we lost like almost all our
YouTube revenue for a while and when
that happened we had this explosion of
new members a lot of those memberships
expired in 2018 and some percentage of
those
had credit cards that expired so we had
more new members than ever in 2017 as a
result of their expiration in 2018 we
lost more members than ever in 2018 so
we had a net loss of several hundred
members last year so yesterday we
launched a massive membership special it
will be the biggest membership special
of the year and there's 24 hours left on
it and it's a yearly membership for 2019
$20.19 okay we had 106 people sign up
yesterday we had another 42 people sign
up today so we've had almost 200 new
members sign up over the last 24 hours
if we can get 10 people from the stream
okay there's 1,300 people right now this
is less than 1% if 10 people right now
go to david pakman.com slash membership
the coupon code is 20 19 2 0 1 9 you've
got to select the $60 per year
membership the coupon code only works
with that membership ok david pakman.com
slash membership yearly $60 is where you
set the slider on the second page you
enter the coupon code 2019 this will
drop the membership price to $20.19 for
the year if 10 people do that okay
that's less than 1% of the people on the
stream I will accept a couple of these
challenges I'm seeing one to three
different challenges right now
make them all 5-minute games I don't
want to bore people like crazy I will
play a couple of the games during the
stream but let's we got to get those
let's get those 10 new members in and I
think it'll be good I might get crushed
by some people okay Kyle prune with a
dollar ninety-nine cent super chat what
are your thoughts on a Warren Sanders
team
I hesitate to talk about this too much
and the reason why is on the one hand I
have been very clear that before the
midterms I wasn't going to talk about
2020 I think we have to focus on the
immediate next thing so to speak
and I didn't and we talked about the
midterms and then now it's time to talk
about 2020 I think that it's premature
to talk about running mates yet when we
don't even know who's running and
starting to talk about Warren Sanders or
Sanders Warren or whatever I don't
really know what we gained because it
starts to get us into the type of
thinking that got us 2016 which is the
sort of calculating who and what is more
electable what's the exact right
combination and when should it be
announced and how will this or that what
I want to focus on right now is I am
going to each day that there is a new
candidate I will evaluate everybody
who's running I will compare their
positions to my political positions and
I will say this is the person that I
support if everybody on Election Day
primary day goes out and votes for the
candidate with whom they most agree with
and nobody stays home because half of
people stay home even more in the
primaries we're gonna be fine okay
so would I vote for a Warren Sanders
ticket of course I would of course I
would vote for a Warren Sanders ticket
but is this the time to start evaluating
that ticket versus another one I don't
think so art Flores is back great to see
art oh boy I can barely even keep up
with these because there are so many
super chats and by the way memberships
are starting to pour in we're looking
for 10 new members using the 2019
discount code and then I'll play a
couple games of chess against people
challenging me on lis chests art Flores
it's inevitable that there will be a
film based on Trump in his
administration which do you find to be
more fitting a drama or a comedy also
your birthday's coming up are you fine
with fans sending gifts no gifts please
the only if you're thinking of sending a
gift send a super chat get a membership
make a pledge on patreon because 2019
the project is I am turning 35 this year
the project is grow the show as much as
possible as a platform to crush it in
2020 when we actually have one of the
most important elections of certainly of
my life so if you you're interested in
sending a gift no gifts if you
want to do something support the show
that's the best thing you can do I think
that the Trump film should be a drama
and it would be a very very or maybe a
dark comedy I don't know but but it
shouldn't be a rom-com style movie for
sure platypi with a five australian
dollar super chat David you're very
intelligent I'm sure you already know
this but did you know that you're also
very attractive 10 out of 10 would bang
smiley face okay please don't turn the
last five seconds of the stream into
tongue some kind of meme because it
could be my undoing the doomsday Channel
$5.00 super chat I make fun of those
conspiracy channels that constantly say
the economy will collapse next week okay
thank you for letting us know
Baron Steuben what is your opinion of
Mexican president Obrador I actually
just did a few minutes on that so I
don't want to do it again
Joe Raider five bucks David you follow
space in science news did you hear about
Ultima Thule very exciting news
tremendous believe me I don't know what
that is Ultima fool let's see what that
is a trans-neptunian object located in
the kippur belt or is it Kuiper it's a
contact binary with estimated dimension
of 35 by 15 kilometers consisting of a
larger body three times the volume of
the smaller I will look into it more
sounds interesting I love space related
stuff Seamus Kay
999 British pounds are we just gonna
forget about the time David promised to
release nudes when he reached a dollar
Target can we make this a thing against
instead of YouTube beta make this a
thing again I never promised to really
release nude pictures Lewis former
producer Lewis may have promised to do
topless but he was topless on the show
ones when he changed shirts during the
show so that's not happening Mads base
with a twenty Danish Krone kronor super
Chad did you ever hear from Reza Aslan
you the man by the way I have never
heard from Reza Aslan no mera vez with
five dollars how did you feel when Jesse
Lee Petersen said alpha males are
conservative
cuz your face was priceless I felt that
the entire thing was just ridiculous and
I treated it as such
Fred phlogiston with a dollar-euro super
chat no question or comment thank you
far-out ideas fYI you have a light
reflecting on the monitor yeah you know
what it is I have a monitor over here
and it reflects on the monitor behind me
and normally I don't have it up but I
need to see the new members that are
coming in and by the way we're about to
get some chess challenges because I said
if we got 10 new members I would play
chess against a few people on LY chess
and pujan bürol Jeremy Kwai Gong uh who
else do we have here
Ghita brawl they're going so fast I can
barely see him Yuko Nohara Ivan Edgard
Maxton Yannone Joseph Armbruster Jack
Simpson
Michael Kristoff Trent tanner wait is
that ten
I think that's nine we're very very
close if if we don't have ten new
members we're about to and then I will
minimize that monitor I won't have to
look at it anymore and I'll play a game
of chess or two I see man a bunch of
challenges stay by your computer because
I feel like the challenges are going to
happen soon okay couple other super
chats The Observer five bucks do you
think stefan molyneux is pushing
eugenics with his race in IQ agenda he
talks about you a lot I am not aware of
stefan molyneux talking about me at all
so if anybody has clips if he I know
that he's been tweeting about me but if
Stefan Molyneux has any video I'm sorry
if anyone has video of stefan molyneux
talking about me email me david at david
pakman.com links and time codes because
i would love to see that and is he
promoting eugenics I don't know is he
promoting a white nationality yes he
absolutely is Fred phlogiston says you
are astonishingly normal by European
standards I don't know if that's a
compliment or an insult
Barun Steuben asks are you planning on
watching the Women's World Cup
probably I'm gonna watch at least some
of it and Nate says David do you like
any hip-hop if so which artist I do I
mostly like older hip-hop I like Tupac
Run DMC yeah I don't know I it's it's
mostly all older stuff and then newer
Latin hip-hop many of you might be
surprised to hear ok mark d'ottavio and
ann kennedy just signed up for
memberships at david pakman.com using
the coupon code 2019 which by the way
drops a $60 membership to $20.19 so why
don't I do what I promised and play a
couple of chess games against people in
the audience let me get set up for this
and I'll just go we'll get back to
politics but I'll just do this since I
promise to war Doge and 5 minute and ops
5 minutes all right let's see let's see
if war Doge is still there and we'll see
provisionally rated way higher than me
of course as you can see my rating only
1161 let's see how I do here King's pawn
opening followed by bringing the Knights
out so far nothing too confusing for me
bringing the bishop out alright I'll
just keep developing here bishop not
pinned because of my pawn on d7 I will
now bring the pawn out now my knight is
pinned at least temporarily
now his knight is pinned to the Queen I
will not keep that feel like I just have
more space here what that is not the
right arrow that I meant to draw I have
more space this way by putting the
bishop where it is now um all right of
course now this other bishop is trapped
what am i doing next mmm I might hang
keto the bishop I'll just bring the
bishop out
look to castle next I hope by the way
that they're not watching the stream it
would be sort of unfair although
hopefully there's enough of a delay that
they're not actually able to react to
what I'm saying I might do I'll keep
pushing forward with the pawns here
Bishop is now stuck because he played b3
I'm guessing he'll take that pond with
either the bishop or the night you did
and I will take the bishop um okay I
think I will do I attack that night or
do I create some space for my bishop
this way I think I do attack the knight
and then if this bishop moves I could
eventually try to put this bishop here
maybe although I don't know if that's
particularly useful I go here takes it
could go here might work down on time a
little but not a huge factor right now
also could take with my bishop hmm take
this way mmm
didn't account for that didn't account
for that where do I go next maybe try to
get the worry I don't want him putting
his knight here because then I'm triple
forked and I have no way of attacking so
maybe I will go here to prevent that
first although then I'm kind of giving
away this pawn that's not a great idea
maybe I'll go here instead already
getting a little dicey for me
be that was a good move maybe I
accidentally stumbled upon a good move
there still forking there but he takes
this bishop
still got nothing I've got to defend
that man that is not the ideal situation
hmm where do I go do I just take this
pawn then he takes here I'd rather him
take the rook and then I take his knight
then take this bishop but I can protect
both here except I can't
maybe I'll go here yeah so I am down now
starting to get very very ugly
take back oh man where do I go next
this bishop is kind of blocked on this
side
he takes it it's also not currently
defended I move it here it's under
attack bill just attack his rook and
force the rook to move
hmm
all right he's at least thinking that's
something I am going to lose this game
but at least it's something okay
could go attack this rook but then his
rook to his a knight would take my
bishop my best next move may be to kick
the night away then I could attack this
rook
depending on where his Knight moves to
still attacking here I think I can and
then I'm forking the knight and the rook
I think this is a good move for me right
this is where I'm missing something and
this is a terrible move we'll find out
soon took that and now he's attacking
the Queen so that may be okay I go here
and attack the rook although I can't
take it because of the pawn is that
really useful I'm better off here good
attack both of them right here yeah
let's try that now see if he moved to
the rook although he's got check right
here yeah missed that move and now I
have no choice but to move my knight
away he'll take but I can take back
unless he doesn't want to attacking both
rooks at once is not a bad thing
hmmm interesting position still probably
losing horribly for me actually he's
having to think about this one for a
while which is which is better than not
I would say if this rook moves it would
be great to be able to attack in this
direction somehow maybe by mmm not even
sure really
maybe doubling up well
that rook moves I would probably take
this one and then the Queen would take
it that one did move I think I take the
rook right and the Queen takes now where
do I go hmm do I attack the rook again
move here this is the real threat right
here which is actually mate in one so I
think I need to do something about that
I need to defend that square and what is
the best way to do it is it this maybe
so can't think of any other obvious way
other than with my queen
not actually getting crushed as badly as
it seemed like it was going to happen
there
by the way I see members pouring in over
here okay so he's kicking the night away
but that's okay because I can go here
and if he doesn't notice then I can fork
the king and rook there although I would
guess he would probably be able to
prevent that in any case I'm immediately
attacking this pawn which isn't a
terrible thing let's see what he does
and of course he's watching the stream
he knows exactly what my strategy is
these are got to put me in check or move
either the Rooker King or and there it
is so now preventing that fork so what
do I want to do next maybe do I want to
use the rook whoops and I accidentally
miss click then that was not what I
meant to do okay but now I've got still
can't do that and now he has broken
beyond this that was a really bad miss
click okay so this would still be
attacking I guess I should try to defend
this Knight
yeah hmm let's see how this goes wish I
hadn't miss clicked there and starting
to get low on time so he wouldn't take
the knight because then I take the Queen
he goes here that's now defended in that
sense that was a good move but that's
the only sense
now what about check over here which
would force the night down here the King
there but then what then what do I do if
I go here that's not good you're maybe I
try to attack the Queen this way mmm
but I need a second defense here that's
the issue I go here he takes I take and
then I lose the Queen that's not good I
think I'm just gonna have to go this
right here and I'm very low on time at
this point
even if that was an okay move I am just
so low on time now that I don't know how
I can recover from this I guess I take
let's try the check I don't even know I
mean it's at least forcing something and
then I'll move back try to gain a little
time yeah this is not looking good that
was a really bad move although mm-hmm
not here oh boy I have no idea at this
point what to do yep I just ran out of
ideas
I completely ran out of ideas they're a
good game appreciate that thanks to
everybody who has been continuing to
send super Jets let me get to some of
these super chats here okay
I may play one more game I'll play one
more game I'll go till 7:00 with super
chats if people want me to play one more
game I will but there are so many super
chats here that I want to get to them I
kill the moolah twenty can't tell what
that is twenty something I don't
recognize that currency symbol Fred
phlogiston with two euros saying simply
compliment Henrik Fredrickson fifty
Danish kroner come to Denmark do your
show on our welfare healthcare system so
that more Americans get to understand
that Bernie's way is the only way for
you I was recently in Denmark and I
absolutely loved it although it was
acutely and painfully expensive and I
live in Boston Massachusetts so that's
saying a lot
hard Greece Saint Cosmo sending a 25
Swiss franc I believe it's Swiss francs
a super chat hey David according to Ray
Diallo it's actually Dali oh I believe
the global economy today is very similar
to the 30s and the tensions us-china
resembles US Japan just before World War
two do you see world war 3 coming soon I
don't see world war 3 coming soon in any
of the ways that would resemble wars a
world war 1 in world war 2
I think World War 3 at this point would
be a very different thing than world war
1 and
nana chuckle were the two Australian
dollar $0.99 super chat 550 good shows
david regards from australia okay
roughen stein Grimson $5 super chat
opinion on freeing americans from
mandatory car ownership by abolishing
zoning building walkable mixed-use
neighborhoods with public transit yes I
have an interview about this
I forget the guests name and I forget
the guests name of the book that we
talked about but yeah absolutely
zoning as well as commercial design and
a whole bunch of other stuff has created
such acute problems when it comes to the
way in which car ownership in many
places is a necessity I mean mandatory
is maybe a step further than I'd go but
it is no doubt a necessity to live a
sort of remotely normal life where you
do normal things so yes absolutely and
totally I got to do more thank yous
because so many people have been signing
up with our coupon code 2019 which gives
you a yearly membership with twenty two
for $20.19 who Joaquim Shaffer
Roberto Millan thank you I think
actually you've named a lot of these
other people so some of these are M
getting duplicate emails here okay I've
got actually go back Barbara Murphy and
Michael Yellin AK that I already think
Michael yellow yellow neck I'm not sure
mark King Patricia Bennett Robert Fraser
and ailing freighter I hope I pronounced
that correctly what a flood I mean truly
what a flood of new members during this
live stream really very much appreciate
it and just amazing absolutely amazing
that this is what's going on today we
have okay so long form pieces we have a
long form piece upcoming about
conspiracy theories it's not going to be
an attack on conspiracy theorists
themselves I know that there are
people in our audience who don't like
that they feel that I am unfairly
attacking conspiracy theorists
i attack bad conspiracy theories but we
are going to do a long-form piece on
conspiracy theories which will talk
about how conspiracy theories work in
terms of the psychological and the way
in which both evidence and absence of
evidence becomes part of the conspiracy
and how that makes the conspiracy in
defeasible in other words you can't
defeat a conspiracy that is based both
on evidence and absence of evidence
being evidence for the conspiracy and I
may not be explaining that in the
clearest way that is upcoming and very
exciting we are going to be producing
that long-form deep dive in partnership
with former TV director Netanya who now
has his own YouTube channel Natanz notes
we are going to be Co producing that
long-form piece with him which is just
great and more on that coming very very
soon as well as a lot of other stuff ok
just because I said I would do two chest
challenges from people in the audience
let me do one more here let's see what
we've got notifications someone says it
would have they would appreciate a
challenge let's go with a well I go with
here the one that was here the earliest
was yes it was this one so I will play
against this person this will be a good
way to wrap up the stream and I will go
first I will try the Queen's Gambit and
see how they play and this could be
another embarrassing loss for me but you
know what when you lose you still learn
ok playing King's gambit Wiens gambit
declined
I actually don't exactly remember this
line but I will go ahead and try to now
develop let's see how we do and please
if you're playing against me turn down
the volume on the stream it seems that
it's unfair to me to continue listening
to the stream while we play ok let's
attack
the Queen and either force the knight to
move or move the bishop back or the
Queen to move going with the bishop now
I will may actually take this pawn I
don't actually know this line if I take
take back doesn't seem logical let's go
here and I will bring the bishop out and
now no point in retaining that pin but
if I move back here I guess I could move
do I move back and then take if the
bishop takes or do I just move back then
I could get up get stuck on the Kings
side yeah I'll move here and then take
if he takes and he did all right
this is clearly a much better player
than me by the way just in case anybody
can't tell although I think you probably
could die um okay let's see looking for
fork ideas here could go here if doesn't
take yeah it doesn't work here and then
here would be interesting except that
and the bishop takes oh that's not a
good idea
mmm this is defended well could defend
that twice we all start pushing the
pawns up on the Queen side a little bit
it's playing very quickly which scares
me every time I see that I assume the
other person is way better than me which
in this case they are all right maybe I
will put the Queen and rook lined up
although then I'm eliminating a backup
square or my bishop he clearly has an
idea of what he wants to do and I don't
that's the that's the interesting thing
although this fork idea now works
because the bishop is blocked although
he moved it out of the way which was
smart and actually the Queen can can
access that as well so that may be that
never worked
let's see maybe I'll go here and if he
takes with the night I can use one of my
pawns to take which one is more
advantageous though he was probably this
one I keep more space I think so what
are the threats here here I would just
take here I would take this is the one
because this one I would not oh no I can
use the Queen still and here I don't
know that I'm not worried about that
night but that's because I'm clueless
what else could I do here I play here
takes this way and then that way but I'm
not yeah that doesn't really make any
sense
do I just exchange here I mean is that
an idea maybe I move here and then maybe
if there's an exchange he would blunder
the Queen I don't know
doesn't seem super likely the way that
this person is playing
so that's not a threat that's not a
threat right now this is not defended
however so do I want to defend that pawn
or do I not care about that pond I think
I do need to defend it which I will do
think this way yeah hmm
so now this pushes forward both my queen
and the knight would be attacked so
maybe I need to get this Knight out of
the way I think I will do that because
now if the pawn comes forward right and
there's that fork the exact fork I was
worried about before okay so I go here
takes here then I take back
and potentially this is an idea at some
point mm-hmm interesting funding that
maybe now I start moving this way this
is a terrible idea
someone tell me
I'm about to get blindsided by some kind
of incredible move I'm thinking here if
it's a free pond although right so I go
here gets my queen out of the way so
what is possible now this is trapped
that's good
blocking that move hmm maybe attack the
Queen
could get the Queen trap do I I guess I
just trade Queens here my position is
not particularly good so I guess I trade
Queens and then start to get some other
kind of attack going and I'm quite low
on time maybe try to double up here and
defend there
need to start pushing some pawns forward
right ah so that's blocking this fork
looks great except I lose the do I want
to exchange maybe that's a good idea
maybe I just try to exchange right here
except now I lose this rook this is why
I'm terrible
some free pawns available but then that
is probably checkmate yes I'll take it
ok so if I go here then the King goes
there is that pointless I guess I'll
just take the pawn for now
second left so this is gonna end very
shortly not with me winning
thanks for playing me by the way I
appreciate it all right that is it I
lost on time okay thank you very much I
got a couple games in we got a ton of
new memberships in let me look at the
last couple of Super chats here before
we wrap Baron Steuben's says Pat 2020
Pat will not be old enough to run for
president in 2020 alright thanks
everybody for joining me thanks to all
the new members I will do more streams
in 2019 and I'm starting strong on
January 2nd thanks new show tomorrow
talk to you soon